hey guys Pete here this is my top
moments of 20 season 3 part 7 it's an
episode that was completely filled with
moments so these are the top of the top
I'm going to try to get through them
pretty quickly because I want to get on
with the rewatch and start doing the
recap and review the plot moved along a
lot here and there's a ton to talk about
but this episode had so many payoffs and
so many awesome moments that I wanted to
put this out first so let's jump right
into it if you haven't watched part 7
yet there will be spoilers from here on
out so the first two moments that I
thought about were funny moments and the
first one was Gary Horn lost in the
woods I cracked up I don't know why not
much happen in the scene other than him
being on the phone with Ben but I just
it just it was just acted well and it
was hilarious to me the next one was
when Frank Truman popped up his computer
in his office that floored me for some
reason I mean it's encased in the wooden
case but there's also like a switch or
like a lever mechanism involved there
that means brings it up like so smoothly
and coolly classic original Twin Peaks
stuff there like a lot of people have
been saying that they're missing all
that original you know flavor or
whatever you would call it and I think
this is exactly what made the early
episodes of Twin Peaks like that sucked
everybody in I mean it's just a quirky
place where you know you don't know
what's going to happen the next big
moment was in Buckhorn South Dakota when
we see the guy who looks like he's
covered with oil or soot walked through
the hospital this is the guy that was in
the jail cell
adjacent to bill Hastings in the first
episode and he's lurking around where
the investigator from the Pentagon is
talking to the police department some
people have said this is the woodsman or
the lumberjack from above the
convenience store you know that seem
that we've seen but we really don't know
who he is and he's not credited at the
end I actually
an interview with this guy who played on
the other day and said that if he was
prayer today that would give up his
whole story so yeah he's the mysterious
guy and he is roaming the halls in the
coroner's office or the hospital
wherever they're at next big moment was
the weird pan into the wood in bang
horns office they were there was a you
know the stretched out scene there with
him and Beverly and when it ended the
camera made a mysterious pan that passed
over the lamp and went into the wood
paneling on the wall this brings up a
lot of speculation material such as the
fact that Josie is trapped in the wood
or was when she died inside the Great
Northern but also if you remember Audrey
had little secret passageways and things
like that behind the walls so yeah
that's it that was kind of a neat thing
that I will definitely be looking at
closer in the recap and review the next
big moment was dougie coupe moving like
a cobra to stop Eike spike we saw agent
Cooper in his dougie life spring to
action and rescue Jamie II who also has
some great moments in this episode that
I won't even get to get to but yeah Ike
the spike shows up with the gun agent
Cooper's FBI instincts come out he
wrestles them to the ground we get an
appearance from the arm who tells him to
squeeze his hand off and then we see
that there's some skin left behind so
that was just incredible and I like the
whole way that that was set up with the
you know the people talking like being
interviewed afterwards Dougie Jones
moved like a cobra the next big moment
or moment I should say is Diane Diane
and I and all of what she did basically
was awesome but her supreme moment was
definitely in the hallway whenever she
asked agent Tammy Preston what was your
name again
Tammy hunters Tammy and Diane says [ __ ]
you Tammy and that was definitely one of
the prized moments of
or episode 7 another funny moment that
just completely I actually went back and
rewound this a couple times when I was
watching it on the first watch was
Gordon saying to Diane when they meet
her at her apartment Diane this might
require a slight change of attitude on
your part and you know I was thinking
about this I won't get into too much of
it but I was thinking about the fact
that if we have to not have Cooper you
know a lot of people are really
concerned and upset about the fact that
Cooper is in his old self which I
understand where they're coming from
having Gordon and Albert together that
sort of functioning in the FBI role here
is at least an equal trade off like we
would never have this much Gordon if
agent Cooper was doing all the
investigation and the other thing is is
you know Albert this is Albert's last
appearance I mean he's passed away
miguel ferrer who plays him so this is
this is really fun to watch everything
with those two and the next moment was
also a golden moment and that was his
explanation of the fingertips and the
backwards ear ev when they met Cooper
evil coupe that is at the prison a
couple episodes back you know he sort of
holds has to Tammy hold out her hands
and he goes across the fingers it's a
rare very good to see you so on and so
forth and explains that the ring finger
the left-handed ring finger is the
spiritual I'd forgot to write it down
but you had the spiritual centre or
whatever he called it so yeah that was
that was really interesting
and I was surprised that they went back
to that in so much detail like when we
when we saw those prints beginning we
were sort of like maybe it's a
continuity error maybe it's that but it
was pretty specifically done in a way
that we would see it and then it would
be explained later so that's pretty
promising when you think about the
season going forward the next big moment
was the body in Buckhorn is probably
major Briggs but we found out that it
didn't actually aged over the last 25
years so that is just a mystery on top
of a mystery there so very interesting
not much more I can say about that right
now
the next big moment was another one I
really laughed at it was evil coupes
photo with his house in Brazil I don't
know why I just the way
was presented and the way Albert said
it's the only photo we have it's so
funny I mean look at it but yeah so we
find out they did have some connection
with evil Cooper before he ended up
where he's at now but very little
information to go along with that and
also it's I didn't pick this out as a
specific moment because the whole
sequence was kind of good but at the end
of the day evil coupe is now up once
again on the loose he's with Rey we
don't know where he's had it but it's
going to definitely lead to something I
mean that's pretty exciting
the next big moment was exactly what if
like if you asked me what would be the
biggest moment I was hoping for in this
episode would be I would have said that
we would find out what was going on with
the diary pages which you know that we
found out that they were absolutely
lowers diary pages thanks to a really
detailed back and forth between Hawke
explaining it to Frank Truman we found
out that not only is it the part where
she talks about what Annie told her in
the dream but also about the Leland
connection and that Leland probably is
the person who left them in there
whenever he was being interviewed for
the chakra gnome what murder
now there's a couple interesting things
one is that this is perfect I know we've
all thought of that idea where you know
mr. agent Cooper's had said if I ever go
missing on TV were looking for me
to hawk and it's pretty perfect how it's
set up in that he is besides agent
Cooper he's the only one that really
kind of buys into the supernatural
explanations of things right off the bat
if it makes sense he's not really
resistant to the idea that there's other
forces at play in things so he came up
with it he was able to explain to Frank
Truman who wasn't there whenever all
this stuff was going on and
unfortunately you know he reached out to
his brother Harry s who was the you know
sheriff back in the original run but he
was too sick to be able to have a
conversation the hawk gets the idea you
know that what Annie Blackburn said as
far as the good Dale being in the lodge
he says if the good Dale is in the laws
then whatever came out of the law
is not the good Dale right so that is
pretty excellent those are things that
you know we've been waiting a long time
to see move forward and they are
officially moving forward and as a side
note you know any Blackburn was kind of
written out in the secret of history of
Twin Peaks as far as being normal sister
like you know normal and in the secret
history Norma's last name is different
the woman who came in on the TV show who
did the restaurant reviews as her mother
is not her mother in the book so that's
something to keep in the back of her
heads for later like I said that would
have been the greatest moment of by far
except for Warren Frost coming back as
doc Hayward was absolutely the scene
stealer just it was the perfect blend of
the original run meets the new season
three that I could possibly imagine we
see hit on that funny-ass wooden
computer pop-up desk thing that Frank
Truman has Doc hailers out enjoying
retirement he said he doesn't member
what he had for breakfast but he does
remember what happened with Cooper and
he dropped some pretty big bombs here he
tells us that he brought him in to check
on him
went to do his rounds and then saw
Cooper fully dressed later coming out of
the ICU where he thinks that he was
probably visiting Audrey Horne who was
in the coma so that is pretty big it's
probably going to lead Frank Truman to
Audrey Horne and we're probably going to
get a payoff there sooner rather than
later because we saw that Frank called
Harry what right away so yeah but it was
just great I mean it was a casual
conversation like with an old friend and
that that's the feeling that I got at
the end of that scene was that I'm you
know I'm interacting with this character
from a show that I loved when I was was
a young man and you know it's just good
to see him I don't know how I better
explain it but it was just awesome and
I'm not sure if we'll get any more doc
Hayward than that but it's really
awesome because as you know Warren Frost
is the actor who played dr. Hayward he
passed away after shooting these scenes
he's the father of Mark frost who's the
co-creator with David Lynch
and this show aired in the US on
Father's Day of 2017 which I imagine is
the first Father's Day that passed since
Warren passed away so yeah it's pretty
powerful this was a great episode I
really don't see how anybody who's
complaining about the pace can complain
after this one I mean several of the
plot point and several of plot lines
move forward great acting great delivery
lots of interesting moments that we just
went over and a ton to speculate on so I
am going to get to work on the recap and
review please like this video if you
enjoyed it make sure to tell me what
your favorite moments were in the
comments subscribe to my channel and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon